其他人:这个巧克力有的没刷完
Others: Some of this chocolate isn't fully covered.
其他人:感觉不够
Others: Feels like it's not enough.
Tasha: 不会吧够了吧
Tasha: No way, it's enough, right?
其他人:好像
Others: Seems like it.
Tasha: 够
Tasha: It's enough.
Tasha: 还多再把巧克力
Tasha: There's still more, let's add more chocolate.
Tasha: 没办法没过去的
Tasha: There's no other way, it didn't pass.
其他人：有几个少
Others: Some are missing a bit.
其他人：这个已经发起来了
Others: This one has already risen.
Tasha: 我感觉快了
Tasha: I think it's almost ready.
其他人：要不拿出来看看
Others: How about taking it out to check?
Tasha: 嗯你闻闻
Tasha: Hmm, smell it.
其他人：鸡蛋确实都是这个味啊
Others: Eggs always smell like this.
Tasha: 确实
Tasha: Indeed.
其他人：要不拿出来看看
Others: How about taking it out to check?
Tasha: 好像没什么问题
Tasha: Seems like there's no problem.
Tasha: 会不会破不会破
Tasha: Will it break? No, it won't.
其他人：你戳一下我
Others: Can you poke me?
Tasha: 我我在想找个筷子呢
Tasha: I'm thinking of finding some chopsticks.
其他人：嗯刚才那有个我洗完的筷子
Others: Yeah, there was a washed one over there just now.
其他人：不我拿筷子
Others: No, I'll get the chopsticks.
Tasha: 没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
其他人：冲一下
Others: Rinse it.
Tasha: 这个干了的
Tasha: This one's dry.
Tasha: 哎拿水拿水
Tasha: Hey, get some water, get some water.
其他人： 不行
Others: It's not working.
其他人：不行不行
Others: It's not working, not working.
其他人：里边还软
Others: It's still soft inside.
Tasha: 不行嗯
Tasha: It's not okay, hmm.
其他人：应该多少温度是不是应该再高一点
Others: What's the temperature? Should we increase it a bit?
Tasha: 再高点就容易把它烤糊吧
Tasha: If we raise it more, it might get burnt.
Tasha: 刚调多少
Tasha: What was it set to just now?
Tasha: 170170
Tasha: 170, 170.
其他人：差不多一直都170
Others: Yeah, it's been at 170.
Tasha: 行再烤个20分钟
Tasha: Okay, bake for another 20 minutes.
Tasha: 了不得了
Tasha: Should be fine.
其他人：这可以加点什么草莓呀
Others: Can we add some strawberries?
Tasha: 这个等考考完再加到上面了
Tasha: Let's add them after it's done baking.
其他人：哦哦行
Others: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 好然后做下一个吗
Tasha: Okay, should we do the next one?
其他人：行我先上个厕所
Others: Sure, I'll go to the bathroom first.
Tasha: ok
Tasha: Ok.
Tasha: 这个就搁这吧
Tasha: Let's just leave this here.
Tasha: 不会掉啊
Tasha: It won't fall, right?
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 麦麦麦麦当劳
Tasha: McDonald's, McDonald's.
其他人：下一个做啥
Others: What's the next one?
Tasha: 巴斯克
Tasha: Basque.
Tasha: 我靠好难啊
Tasha: Oh gosh, this is hard.
Tasha: 算了做提拉米苏吧
Tasha: Forget it, let's make tiramisu.
Tasha: 做提拉米苏吧
Tasha: Let's make tiramisu.
其他人：这个这个叫啥来着
Others: What's this called again?
Tasha: 蘸酱麻薯这
Tasha: Dipping mochi, this.
Tasha: 个超级简单
Tasha: It's super easy.
其他人：它那个麻薯的口感怎么做出来的 糯米粉
Others: How do you get that mochi texture? Glutinous rice flour?
Tasha:  麻薯口感怎么做
Tasha: How to get the mochi texture.
Tasha: 加热加黄油就可以了
Tasha: Just heat it and add butter, that's it.
其他人：这么神奇
Others: That's amazing.
其他人：做啥
Others: What to make?
Tasha: 做提拉米苏吧
Tasha: Let's make tiramisu.
其他人：这个有点太夸张了
Others: This is a bit too much.
其他人： 其实他那个上边如果稍微糊一点
Others: Actually, if it's slightly burnt on top,
其他人： 我觉得可能就
Others: I think it might be
其他人：说明快好了
Others: almost done.
其他人：希望他加热的比较均匀
Others: Hope it heats evenly.
其他人：这个怎么办
Others: What to do with this?
Tasha: 这个等这个烤好就送进去
Tasha: Wait until this bakes and then put it in.
其他人：哎你们这一天用这个平底锅吗
Others: Hey, did you use this pan all day?
Tasha: 平底锅没有吧
Tasha: We don't have that pan, right?
其他人：这有吗
Others: Do we have it?
Tasha: 只有平底锅哦
Tasha: Only this pan.
Tasha: 你想煎牛排是吧
Tasha: You want to fry a steak, right?
其他人：那个牛排虽然不错
Others: That steak looks good though.
Tasha: 好问题
Tasha: Good question.
Tasha: 有平底锅吗
Tasha: Do we have a pan?
Tasha: 没有呀好像
Tasha: Seems like we don't.
Tasha: 你翻翻柜子
Tasha: Check the cabinet.
Tasha: 你你可以现在找吧
Tasha: You can look for it now.
其他人：没事我应该一会在这
Others: It's okay, I should be here for a while.
其他人：着快递啥情况
Other people: What's up with this delivery?
Tasha: 这的快递吗
Tasha: Is this the delivery?
Tasha: 就是只能在一个点取
Tasha: You can only pick it up at one point.
Tasha: 他好像不会送到门上
Tasha: It seems like they won't deliver it to your door.
Tasha: 提拉米苏来
Tasha: Tiramisu is coming.
其他人：那个可可粉你买了不是吗
Other people: Didn't you buy that cocoa powder?
Tasha: 买过了呀咋了
Tasha: Yeah, I bought it. Why?
其他人：没事我就问问
Other people: Nothing, just asking.
其他人：着好像有锅不是平底锅
Other people: It seems like this pot isn't a frying pan.
Tasha: 也可以吧
Tasha: It should be fine.
其他人：刷一下一会把牛排煎了
Other people: Just brush it and we'll sear the steak later.
Tasha: 你很会煎牛排吗
Tasha: Are you good at searing steak?
其他人：嗯
Other people: Yeah.
Tasha: 我说很会煎牛排吗
Tasha: I asked if you are good at searing steak?
其他人：我吗
Other people: Me?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人：着有啥会不会的熟了就行
Other people: It doesn't matter, as long as it's cooked.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
其他人：也不可能不熟
Other people: It can't be undercooked anyway.
其他人： 而且我很会做饭
Other people: Plus, I'm really good at cooking.
Tasha: 哇真的吗
Tasha: Wow, really?
Tasha: 好怎么没让你来露一手
其他人： 拍降维打击
Other people: Shoot a dimension reduction strike.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 他说什么
Tasha: What did he say?
其他人： 没听见
Other people: Didn't hear it.
Tasha: 这不是我的
Tasha: This isn't mine.
Tasha: 那你煎牛排要用黄油吗
Tasha: Do you need butter to sear the steak?
其他人：不用也可以用
Other people: You can use it or not.
Tasha: 在冰箱里
Tasha: It's in the fridge.
其他人：但是他们那个黄油一般都是厚的
Other people: But their butter is usually thick.
其他人： 就是那个黄油化了以后你把那个汁
Other people: After melting the butter, pour the juice over it.
其他人：然后浇上去
Other people: Then pour it over.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
其他人： 因为黄油本身苦
Other people: Because butter itself is bitter.
其他人：就是缪肉黄油的话肯定苦
Other people: If it's pure butter, it'll definitely be bitter.
其他人：所以这个锅我感觉
Other people: So I think this pot...
其他人:现在煎吗
Other people: Should we sear it now?
其他人：现在煎
Other people: Let's sear it now.
其他人:或者等他们回来
Other: Or wait for them to come back.
其他人:等他们回来吧
Other: Let's wait for them to come back.
其他人：你还买黄油了是吗
Other: Did you also buy butter?
Tasha: 是的买了
Tasha: Yes, I bought it.
其他人：我靠这个好危险啊
Other: Wow, this is really dangerous.
Tasha: 你找得到更合适的地方吗
Tasha: Can you find a more suitable place?
其他人：这
Other: This...
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
其他人：我操充电宝放这
Other: Damn, the power bank is here.
Tasha: 现在就开始煎是吗
Tasha: Are we starting to fry it now?
Tasha: 哦哇你还挺有生活常识的嘞
Tasha: Oh wow, you actually have a lot of common sense.
其他人：啊挺香的
Other: Ah, it smells good.
其他人：这个
Other: This...
Tasha: 没熟
Tasha: It's not cooked.
其他人：就他这样裂开就说明差不多了是吗
Other: If it splits like this, does it mean it's almost done?
Tasha: 没有里面没熟
Tasha: No, it's not cooked inside.
Tasha: 这个倒进去这三个
Tasha: Pour these three in.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
其他人：我靠我还挺懂呢
Other: Wow, I actually understand this.
Tasha: 这太懂了吧你
Tasha: You understand this too well.
其他人：直接撕吧没有剪刀
Other: Just tear it, there's no scissors.
Tasha: 能撕的开吗
Tasha: Can you tear it open?
Tasha: 我去帮你拿个剪刀
Tasha: I'll get you a pair of scissors.
其他人：这的拿那个厨房剪刀吧
Other: Use the kitchen scissors.
Tasha: 我有
Tasha: I have them.
Tasha: 刀把啊
Tasha: Knife handle.
Tasha: 捋开是吗
Tasha: Smooth it out, right?
其他人：对搁这个边上
Other: Yeah, put it on the edge.
Tasha: 哎到这
Tasha: Hey, up to here.
其他人：奶油吗这个是
Other: Is this cream?
Tasha: 马斯卡彭
Tasha: Mascarpone.
其他人：好高级干啥用的
Other: Wow, what's it used for?
Tasha: 做提拉米苏专用
Tasha: It's for making tiramisu.
Tasha: 你可以把这个边边都拿开
Tasha: You can remove all the edges.
Tasha: 这样的话就完全挤出来
Tasha: That way, it will squeeze out completely.
Tasha: 黑笔我上楼拿一下
Tasha: I'll go upstairs to get a black pen.
Tasha: 正儿八经剪刀
Tasha: Proper scissors.
其他人:黑笔是干什么
Other: What's the black pen for?
Tasha: 好好吃吗
Tasha: Is it tasty?
Alice:可以
Alice: It's good.
其他人：美味是啊
Others: Delicious, right?
Tasha: 是啊这些东西都美味
Tasha: Yeah, all of these are delicious.
Tasha: 要加糖的
Tasha: You need to add sugar.
其他人：酸度调节剂
Others: Acidity regulator.
Alice:是不跟吃油一样嗯
Alice: It's not the same as eating oil, right?
其他人：嗯
Others: Mm-hmm.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha!
Alice:好好笑
Alice: So funny.
其他人:这就是奶奶加油的黄油也是
Others: It's like the butter grandma uses.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
其他人:四个三个都加进去
Others: Put in all three or four.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 这这剪刀
Tasha: These scissors...
其他人：这种干净吗
Others: Are these clean?
Tasha: 我觉得
Tasha: I think so.
其他人:你把那个这样
Others: You do it like this...
其他人:把这个给
Others: Give this...
其他人:打开我还是拿刀吧
Others: Open it. I'll just use the knife.
其他人:这下边俩角没开
Others: The two corners at the bottom aren't open.
Tasha: 我没开完呢
Tasha: I haven't finished opening it.
Tasha: 你让我接这个了
Tasha: You told me to take this over.
其他人:好问题不大
Others: It's alright, no big deal.
Tasha: 不能浪费
Tasha: Can't waste it.
其他人：不用倒特别干净
Others: No need to pour it all out perfectly.
Tasha: 不用倒特别干净
Tasha: No need to pour it all out perfectly.
Tasha: 很贵的这个
Tasha: This stuff is expensive.
其他人:是吗
Others: Really?
Tasha: 是啊这一包多少钱
Tasha: Yeah, how much is this pack?
其他人:这一包多少钱
Others: How much is this pack?
Tasha: 一包二三十啊
Tasha: One pack is twenty or thirty.
Alice:一盒得二三十吧
Alice: One box is about twenty or thirty, right?
其他人：卧槽那提拉米苏这么成本这么高
Others: Whoa, so tiramisu costs so much to make.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 尤其是如果你想做很垃圾的提拉米苏
Tasha: Especially if you want to make a really good tiramisu.
Tasha: 其实很便宜
Tasha: It's actually quite cheap.
Tasha: 但是想要做很纯正的就很贵
Tasha: But if you want to make an authentic one, it's expensive.
其他人： 这个大概能
Others: This can probably...
Alice:做一排
Alice: Make one batch.
Tasha: 12个吧
Tasha: About twelve.
Alice:对然后一一盘
Alice: Yes, then one plate.
Tasha: 对就是一板
Tasha: Yes, just one tray.
Tasha: 就刚刚那么就这么大一盘
Tasha: Just like that, a tray this big.
其他人:那一个做4个
Others: Make four with one.
Tasha: 对所以挑
Tasha: Yes, so pick...
其他人:这一个就卖68
Others: This one sells for 68.
Tasha: 对啊所以才会卖的贵吧我觉得
Tasha: Yeah, so that's why it's expensive, I think.
Tasha: 而且这用的都是最好的原料了
Tasha: And we use the best ingredients.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mhm.
Alice:我们买抹茶粉也是很好的
Alice: We also buy really good matcha powder.
其他人:提拉米苏能做抹茶味
Others: You can make matcha-flavored tiramisu.
Alice:那就是你的那个胚跟底是一样的
Alice: So the base and the bottom are the same.
Tasha: 撒抹茶粉
Tasha: Just sprinkle matcha powder on top.
Alice:就看你上面撒什么粉
Alice: It depends on what you sprinkle on top.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mhm.
其他人:那一会做个抹茶的吧
Others: Let's make a matcha one later.
Tasha: 行你想做啥的都行
Tasha: Sure, you can make whatever you want.
其他人:搅
Others: Stir it.
Tasha: 啊等等
Tasha: Ah, wait a sec.
Alice:用那个打发
Alice: Use that to whip it.
Tasha: 搅拌就一直划到它顺
Tasha: Just keep stirring until it's smooth.
其他人:哦就跟那个面包似的
Others: Oh, like making bread.
其他人:做那个蛋糕似的
Others: Like making a cake.
Alice:你做过蛋糕吗
Alice: Have you ever made a cake?
你做过蛋糕吗
Have you made a cake before?
其他人:没做过但我看看
Others: No, but I've seen it done.
Alice:其实想做
Alice: I actually want to try.
其他人: 等下过生日去做
Others: Let's make one for the next birthday.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mhm.
Alice:有很多那种什么情侣的那个
Alice: There are lots of couples' activities like that.
其他人: 什么项目
Others: What kind of activities?
Tasha: 我今天买了淡奶油呢
Tasha: I bought some heavy cream today.
Alice:在右边吗
Alice: Is it on the right?
Tasha: 不在
Tasha: No, it's not.
其他人:这我得按一个方向搅
Others: I have to stir this in one direction.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
其他人:如果不是会怎么样
Others: What happens if you don't?
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Tasha: 我今买的淡奶油呢
Tasha: I bought heavy cream today.
Alice:放进去了吗
Alice: Did you put it in?
Tasha: 我今天放进来了呀
Tasha: I put it in today.
Tasha: 难道被拿到楼上去了
Tasha: Could it have been taken upstairs?
其他人：这这这
Others: This this this...
Tasha: 哎谁拿出来的
Tasha: Hey, who took it out?
其他人:你拿出来的吧
Others: Maybe you took it out?
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
Alice:这是今天买的还是上次买的呀
Alice: Is this bought today or from last time?
Tasha: 今天刚到
Tasha: Just arrived today.
Tasha: 哎今天啊这个也是今天买的
Tasha: Oh, this is also bought today.
其他人:今天买的今天买的
Others: Bought today, bought today.
Tasha: 盆哎
Tasha: The basin, hey.
其他人:可以了吗
Others: Is it okay?
Tasha: 可以了呀然后放上来呃好吧
Tasha: It's okay, then put it up, uh, alright.
其他人:就稍微一弄就行
Others: Just adjust it a bit.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's alright.
Alice:无妨
Alice: No problem.
Tasha: 你这样子
Tasha: Like this.
Tasha: 这样
其他人:等等等等
Others: Wait, wait, wait.
Tasha: 没关系叫500颗
Tasha: It's fine, just call it 500 pieces.
Tasha: 这个这袋子用完就
Tasha: This bag will be used up.
其他人:他这上面不是写了大概多少克
Others: Doesn't it say approximately how many grams on it?
Tasha: 这个还真是被点了就
Tasha: This really has been counted.
其他人:嗯哦哦
Others: Hmm, oh oh.
Alice:小半一点点
Alice: Just a little bit more.
Tasha: 捋开
Tasha: Smooth it out.
其他人:可不好拿刀剪
Others: It's hard to cut with a knife.
其他人:剪刀刚才剪刀呢
Others: Where are the scissors we used just now?
Tasha: 剪刀
Tasha: Scissors.
Alice:那那那
Alice: There, there, there.
其他人：加500
Others: Add 500.
Tasha: 对加500一共500
Tasha: Yes, add 500, total 500.
Tasha: 刚才你加了130了
Tasha: You just added 130.
Tasha: 可以了吧
Tasha: Is it okay now?
Tasha: 用这个用这个
Tasha: Use this, use this.
其他人:就这
Others: This one.
其他人:现在那个披萨只能加这么多东西
Others: Now that pizza can only add so many things.
Tasha: 把它搅拌
Tasha: Stir it up.
Alice:还得加蛋液吧
Alice: Should we add egg mixture too?
Tasha: 对这这个这个
Tasha: Yes, this, this, this.
Tasha: 蛋液什么的要先去啊
Tasha: The egg mixture needs to go first.
其他人:没事弄熟了我去搞
Others: No problem, I'll handle it once it's cooked.
Tasha: 我去搞蛋液那一部分啊
Tasha: I'll take care of the egg mixture part.
Tasha: 你把它打发成那种膏状
Tasha: You need to whisk it until it becomes a paste.
Alice:需要我帮你什么吗
Alice: Do you need my help with anything?
Tasha: 不用嗯不用
Tasha: No, no need.
Tasha: 很简单
Tasha: It's very simple.
Alice:手指饼干呢
Alice: What about the ladyfingers?
Alice:我给他拿出来吧
Alice: I'll get them out.
其他人:这就跟调麻酱
Others: It's like making sesame paste.
Alice:酒
Alice: The liquor.
Alice:哎手指饼干在哪里
Alice: Hey, where are the ladyfingers?
Tasha: 手指饼干在这呢
Tasha: The ladyfingers are here.
Tasha: 60克水
Tasha: 60 grams of water.
Alice:你是要沾这个液吧
Alice: You need to dip it in this liquid, right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
其他人:像那个就是蛋糕上面抹
Others: It's like spreading on top of a cake.
Alice:奶油
Alice: Cream.
其他人:奶油抹也可以这么做
Others: You can spread the cream like this too.
Tasha: 你不是加带奶油进去了吗
Tasha: Didn't you add cream to it?
其他人:他那那他那种奶就是那种奶油
Others: Yes, it's that kind of cream.
Alice:就是是牛奶打发
Alice: It's whipped milk.
其他人:就牛奶加
Others: Just milk plus...
其他人:这个洗奶油
Others: ...this whipped cream.
Alice:不用就是牛奶加糖
Alice: No, it's just milk and sugar.
Tasha: 牛奶加糖
Tasha: Milk and sugar.
其他人:加糖
Others: Add sugar.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
其他人:那为什么刚才打的那个你说不是
Others: Then why did you say it wasn't just now?
Tasha: 刚打哪个
Tasha: Which one did you whip?
其他人:那个就是
Others: That one...
Tasha: 那个没加带奶油呀我们
Tasha: We didn't add cream to that one.
其他人:你刚不是说牛奶加糖
Others: Didn't you say milk and sugar?
其他人:就是淡奶油啊
Others: That's light cream.
其他人:淡奶油加牛奶加糖
Others: Light cream plus milk and sugar.
Alice:什么没听懂
Alice: What? I didn't get it.
其他人:就是那个蛋糕上面那个奶
Others: It's the cream on top of the cake.
Alice:那个就是奶加糖打
Alice: That's milk whipped with sugar.
Alice:但是你用手打打不出来
Alice: But you can't do it by hand.
Alice:得用那个高速的打
Alice: You need to use a high-speed mixer.
其他人:哦对啊
Others: Oh yeah.
其他人:那咱刚才做的那个
Others: So what we just did...
其他人:第一个不就是加了这些吗
Others: The first one, didn't we just add these?
Tasha: 没加这些呀
Tasha: We didn't add these.
其他人:咱第一个不是加水和油
Others: Didn't we add water and oil first?
其他人: 然后就然后就加了那个蛋清和糖吗
Others: Then we added the egg whites and sugar, right?
Tasha: 哦所以才问奶油问
Tasha: Oh, so that's why we asked about the cream.
其他人: 所以那不就是蛋糕奶油吗
Others: So isn't that just cake cream?
Alice:不用奶油不用加鸡蛋
Alice: No need for cream, no eggs.
其他人: 要不说奶和糖就是奶和糖
Others: Just milk and sugar, that's it.
Alice:奶和糖是奶油
Alice: Milk and sugar make cream.
Alice:不加鸡蛋
Alice: No eggs.
其他人:要加油吗
Others: Do we need oil?
Alice:不加
Alice: No.
其他人:真的吗
Others: Really?
Alice:骗你干嘛
Alice: Why would I lie to you?
其他人:那是旺仔牛奶
Others: That's Wangzai milk.
其他人:直接把旺仔牛奶搅拌
Others: Just mix the Wangzai milk.
其他人:再搅拌搅拌就是奶油
Others: Mix it more and it's cream.
Alice:旺仔牛奶
Alice: Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 刚刚你那一个鸡蛋
Tasha: Your egg just now...
Tasha: 哦搁这呢
Tasha: Oh, it's here.
Alice:不太行吧
Alice: Not really.
Alice:旺仔牛奶可以了
Alice: Wangzai milk is fine.
其他人:可以了
Others: It's good.
其他人:这边抹到抹到什么上面
Others: Spread it on... what?
Alice:这个还得加可生食鸡蛋的蛋液
Alice: You still need to add edible raw egg liquid.
其他人:蛋清
Others: Egg whites.
Alice:不是蛋液的蛋黄吧
Alice: No, egg yolk from the liquid.
其他人：你在这嗑吧
Others: You crack it here.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人:还要加什么
Others: What else to add?
Alice:打黄叶吧
Alice: Beat the yolk.
Tasha: 接那个跑腿
Tasha: Pass that runner task.
Tasha: 你接你接
Tasha: You pass it, you pass it.
Tasha: 不用不用
Tasha: No need, no need.
Tasha: 好了好了你说吧
Tasha: Okay, okay, you speak.
Tasha: 你跟他说话
Tasha: You talk to him.
其他人:喂你好
Others: Hello?
其他人:啊您在哪
Others: Ah, where are you?
Tasha: 您出去找他吧
Tasha: You go out and find him.
其他人:在53号楼门口是吧
Other: At the entrance of building 53, right?
其他人：好好好我们去找你
Other: Okay, okay, we'll go find you.
其他人：好好一会见
Other: Alright, see you later.
其他人:那我去吧
Other: Then I'll go.
Alice:你能拿着吗
Alice: Can you hold this?
Alice:我跟你一块
Alice: I'll go with you.
行
Alright.
Tasha: 对有好多
Tasha: Yes, there are many.
其他人：直接把手机给我
Other: Just give me the phone.
Tasha: 签收码是吗
Tasha: It's the signing code, right?
其他人：对
Other: Yes.
Tasha: 166821
其他人：你开一下要不
Other: Can you open it?
Tasha: 就就是签收码就行是吧
Tasha: So just the signing code, right?
其他人：对
Other: Yes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Okay.
其他人：行就这个给他看
Other: Alright, just show him this.
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Tasha: 62点多怎么办呢
Tasha: What do we do with 62 points?
Alice:呜有空位吗
Alice: Is there an empty spot?
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice:这搁哪
Alice: Where to put this?
Tasha: 放地上吧
Tasha: Put it on the ground.
Alice:放地上我们在二楼还是一楼吃
Alice: On the ground? Are we eating on the second floor or the first floor?
Tasha: 哦那应该在二楼吃是吧
Tasha: Oh, I think we're eating on the second floor, right?
Alice:在一楼吧
Alice: Let's eat on the first floor.
Tasha: 在一楼这怎么吃
Tasha: How do we eat on the first floor?
Alice:要不你看阳台
Alice: How about you check the balcony?
Alice:哎不是阳台
Alice: Oh, not the balcony.
Tasha: 哦外面是吗
Tasha: Oh, outside, right?
Alice:外面有位吗
Alice: Is there a spot outside?
Tasha: 应该可以在外
Tasha: It should be okay outside.
Alice:上外边吧
Alice: Let's go outside.
Tasha: 我靠完了
Tasha: Oh no, it's over.
Tasha: 有140颗蛋
Tasha: There are 140 eggs.
Alice:就在一楼吧搁地上吧
Alice: Let's stay on the first floor, put it on the ground.
Alice:2楼打扫干净
Alice: The second floor is cleaned.
Alice:不要再增加工作量
Alice: Don't add more workload.
其他人：我看看
Other: Let me take a look.
其他人：饮料可以放在桌子上
Others: You can put the drinks on the table.
Jake:谢可以在这继续走吧
Jake: Thanks, we can keep going here, right?
Alice:咖啡
Alice: Coffee.
Tasha: 差不多是高中了
Tasha: It's almost like high school.
其他人：这个也太大了
Others: This is too big.
其他人：这你做的啥呀啊那个那个
Others: What are you doing with that, uh, that thing?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
其他人：有遥控器吗我把空调开开
Others: Do we have a remote? I want to turn on the air conditioner.
Tasha: 你拿出来吧倒倒扣
Tasha: You should take it out, turn it upside down.
Tasha: 我说拿出来倒扣
Tasha: I said take it out and turn it upside down.
其他人：有遥控器吗
Others: Is there a remote?
Tasha: 遥控器好像在楼上
Tasha: The remote might be upstairs.
Tasha: 随便放哪吧
Tasha: Just put it anywhere.
Tasha: 是扣在那个晾晒盆上
Tasha: Put it upside down on the drying rack.
Tasha: 晾晒网上对
Tasha: On the drying net, yeah.
其他人：这个
Others: This one?
Tasha: 隔的东西太多了
Tasha: There are too many things in the way.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
其他人：扣案板上也可以
Others: You can also put it on the cutting board.
Tasha: 扣这个板上
Tasha: On this board.
Tasha: 晾晒网上
Tasha: On the drying net.
其他人：扣案板上不行你吃了吧
Others: No, putting it on the cutting board doesn't work, you should eat it.
其他人：这还没洗呢
Others: It hasn't been washed yet.
Tasha: 拿湿巾擦一下吧
Tasha: Wipe it with a wet wipe.
其他人：这个吗
Others: This one?
其他人：有湿巾吗没有
Others: Do we have wet wipes? No, we don't.
Tasha: 拿清水餐巾纸擦一擦
Tasha: Wipe it with a napkin and some clean water.
其他人：哎就这样吧
Others: Ah, just leave it like that.
其他人： 不如上边垫一层那个
Others: How about we put a layer on top?
其他人： 你先让一下
Others: Can you move a bit?
其他人：直接倒扣过去
Others: Just turn it upside down directly.
Tasha: 这样子你拿着这个然后倒啊行行行
Tasha: Hold this and then turn it, okay, okay.
其他人：那它就压了
Others: It will get pressed down.
Tasha: 是呀是会压到呀
Tasha: Yeah, it will get pressed down.
其他人：不行这样我扣不了
Others: No, I can't do it this way.
其他人：不行不行这样我扣不了
Others: No, no, I can't do it this way.
其他人：我怎么给他翻过去
Others: How am I supposed to flip it over?
其他人：啊我想想
Others: Ah, let me think.
Alice:烫吗
Alice: Is it hot?
其他人：下边这个很难下边这个铁烫
Others: The bottom part is difficult, the iron part is hot.
其他人：想想这个怎么你拿
Others: Think about how you're gonna take this
Alice:你搁那
Alice: Put it there
其他人：你先给他这么揍过去
Others: You should give it to him like this
Tasha: 你唉
Tasha: You, hey
其他人：不你推你退你直接把它推过去
Others: No, push it, just push it over
Tasha: 天哪
Tasha: Oh my God
其他人：你推你戴着手套
Others: Push it while wearing gloves
其他人：ok
Others: Okay
其他人：对这不就完了
Others: Yeah, that's it
Tasha: 好了赶紧把这个这个蛋挞送进去
Tasha: Alright, hurry and get this egg tart in
其他人：等会等会这个盘
Others: Wait, wait, this tray
Tasha: 就放这
Tasha: Just put it here
其他人：这么随意
Others: So casual
Tasha: 丹塔送进去
Tasha: Send in the egg tart
Tasha: 200度烤20分钟
Tasha: 200 degrees for 20 minutes
其他人：你的这个熔岩还在表面
Others: Your lava is still on the surface
Tasha: 一两个的表妹
Tasha: A couple of them are on the surface
Tasha: 没关系 20分钟200度
Tasha: It's okay, 20 minutes at 200 degrees
Tasha: 上下火都200度
Tasha: 200 degrees both top and bottom
其他人：这个好像没法调好可以200度
Others: This seems hard to adjust, but okay, 200 degrees
其他人：是挺高级
Others: It's pretty high-end
其他人：这个还能上下
Others: It can do both top and bottom
其他人：上下指定问题
Others: Top and bottom is a must
Tasha: 你你你等他不在了你才说这个
Tasha: You, you, you wait until he's gone before saying this
Tasha: 他还以为我租什么垃圾的过来了
Tasha: He might think I rented some garbage
其他人：哦这是你带的吧
Others: Oh, this is what you brought?
Tasha: 对这是租的烤箱
Tasha: Yeah, it's a rented oven
Tasha: 还没放和肉松呀
Tasha: Haven't added the pork floss yet
其他人：你要多少度
Others: What temperature do you want?
Tasha: 82度 82度啊怎么了
Tasha: 82 degrees, 82 degrees, what's up?
其他人： 82度
Others: 82 degrees?
其他人：我以为你到200度
Others: I thought you meant 200 degrees
Tasha: 200多都不会太夸张
Tasha: Even 200 degrees wouldn't be too much
其他人：这啥味啊
Others: What's that smell?
其他人：很难闻
Others: It smells bad
Tasha: 知道这个锅是怎么被烤浆的吗
Tasha: Do you know how this pot got baked?
其他人：就是你糖加的太多了
Others: You added too much sugar
其他人：它底下底不会都糊了吧
Others: The bottom is completely burnt, right?
其他人：你那那个搅
Others: Stir that thing
其他人:这一会底感觉要糊啊
Others: The bottom feels like it's about to burn
Tasha: 不会的
Tasha: No way.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's over.
其他人:糊了
Others: It's burnt.
Alice:熟了你先给它倒出来
Alice: It's done, you should pour it out first.
其他人:你先给它倒出来
其他人:然后再换
Others: Then switch.
其他人:换个盆
Others: Change the bowl.
Tasha: 过筛一下吧等会
Tasha: Let's sift it first, wait a moment.
其他人：换个盆加热
Others: Change the bowl and heat it up.
Tasha: 怎么熟这么快我靠
Tasha: How did it cook so fast, damn.
Alice:是是熟了吗
Alice: Is it really done?
Tasha: 没有没有没有没关系
Tasha: No, no, no, it's fine.
Alice:你你是哪个学院的
Alice: Which school are you from?
其他人:哪个学院
Others: Which school?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 应该是计算机吧
Tasha: I think it's Computer Science.
其他人:人人工智能计算机好没
Others: Isn't Artificial Intelligence part of Computer Science?
Alice:不是你们那个全称叫啥
Alice: No, what's your full title?
其他人:就叫人工智能
Others: It's just called Artificial Intelligence.
Alice:人工智能学院嗯
Alice: The School of Artificial Intelligence, right?
其他人：嗯然后人工智能专业
Tasha: OK没关系没关系小问题
Tasha: Okay, it's fine, it's fine, just a minor issue.
其他人：你连火箭都不关
Others: You didn't even turn off the rocket.
Tasha: 哎呀这很着急
Tasha: Oh, this is really urgent.
Alice:帮你搅一下
Alice: I'll help you stir it.
其他人:我怕你烫到我
Others: I'm afraid you'll burn me.
其他人:开空调哈哈哈
Others: Turn on the air conditioner, haha.
其他人:你们不热吗
Others: Aren't you guys hot?
Alice:有一点
Alice: A little bit.
Tasha: 我觉得
Tasha: I think...
Tasha: 还需要再打几个可食用鸡蛋进去
Tasha: We need to add a few more edible eggs.
Tasha: 不然鸡蛋不够
Tasha: Otherwise, there won't be enough eggs.
Alice:蛋液用生的不加热应该也行
Alice: Using raw egg yolk without heating should work too.
Tasha: 嗯只不过刚
Tasha: Yeah, just...
Tasha: 为了让那几个东西充分融合一下
Tasha: To make those things blend well.
其他人:我开空调呢
Others: I'm turning on the air conditioner.
Alice:有没有那个万能遥控
Alice: Is there a universal remote?
Tasha: 再搞两个蛋清蛋黄进去
Tasha: Let's add two more egg whites and yolks.
Alice:有个按钮
Alice: There's a button.
其他人:真的假的
Others: Really?
Alice:我得看看
Alice: I need to take a look.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
其他人:感觉不太对
Others: It doesn't feel right.
Alice:有的是有按钮的呀
Alice: Some of them do have buttons.
Alice:找到了吗
Alice: Did you find it?
其他人：好像开了
Others: Seems like it's on.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Let's leave it like this.
Alice:吹不了多久了
Alice: It won't blow for long.
其他人：这18度
Others: It's 18 degrees.
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Awesome.
其他人：16度16度
Others: 16 degrees, 16 degrees.
Tasha: 这么热
Tasha: It's so hot.
Alice:你妈看见不打你
Alice: Won't your mom hit you if she sees this?
Alice:你吃过你们想要那个包子吗
Alice: Have you eaten the buns you wanted?
其他人:嗯我们学校给包的啊
Others: Yeah, our school provides them.
其他人:我学习都没咋去过学校
Others: I barely went to school for my studies.
其他人:我四年都没咋去过学校
Others: I barely went to school for four years.
其他人:一直翘课
Others: Skipped class all the time.
其他人:因为那些课没啥用
Others: Because those classes were useless.
其他人:基本都是
Others: Mostly.
其他人:考前一周突击一下就结束嗯
Others: Just crammed a week before exams and done.
Alice:热呀
Alice: It's hot.
其他人：咋了这个事都已经传到你那了
Others: What, this news has already reached you?
Alice:我第一时间是关于
Alice: My first reaction was about...
Alice:我的朋友
Alice: My friend.
Alice:他给我发了那个完整的PDF
Alice: He sent me the complete PDF.
Alice:他他他
Alice: He, he, he...
Alice:是啊
Alice: Yeah.
其他人：你朋友北邮的
Others: Your friend is from BUPT?
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
其他人:哪个院的
Others: Which department?
Alice:忘记了
Alice: Forgot.
Alice:也是那种吧
Alice: It's one of those.
其他人:叫啥
Others: What's his name?
Alice:不想说万一你知道呢
Alice: Don't want to say, what if you know him?
Tasha: 抖音
Tasha: TikTok.
其他人:那就更巧了
Others: That would be even more coincidental.
Alice:不说哈哈
Alice: Not saying, haha.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
其他人：我这四年都没咋认识
Others: I didn't get to know anyone in these four years.
其他人：认识不是更好吗
Others: Isn't it better to know each other?
其他人:给你煎个蛋白吃
Others: I'll fry an egg white for you.
其他人:怎么样
Others: How's that?
Alice:温度越高凉的越快
Alice: The higher the temperature, the faster it cools.
其他人:是吗
Others: Really?
Alice:他那个有一个什么什么一个曲线的
Alice: There's some kind of curve or something.
其他人：还是烫但是短暂拿一两秒没有关系
Others: It's still hot, but it's okay to take it for a second or two.
其他人：还是先拿出来把看看一会谁吃一个
Others: Better take it out first and see who eats it.
其他人:昨天烧烤
Others: Yesterday's barbecue.
其他人:在哪在哪搞
Others: Where did you do it?
Alice:昨天还是前天吧
Alice: Was it yesterday or the day before?
Alice:我们就在医院里
Alice: We were at the hospital.
Alice:对买的炭
Alice: Yes, we bought some charcoal.
其他人:卧槽
Others: Whoa.
其他人：能吃吗这个功能是
Others: Can you eat it? What's the function?
Alice:这是充的气
Alice: It's inflated.
Alice:保鲜的
Alice: To keep it fresh.
Alice:你是准备读研工作还是出国读研
Alice: Are you planning to go to grad school, work, or study abroad for grad school?
其他人:就是在他们组
Others: Just in their group.
其他人:就是去NTU
Others: Just going to NTU.
其他人:你是研一是吗
Others: Are you a first-year grad student?
Alice:研二
Alice: Second-year.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
其他人:那你现在还挣钱
Others: Are you still earning money now?
其他人:准备毕业是吧
Others: Getting ready to graduate, right?
Alice:我是三年的
Alice: I'm in a three-year program.
其他人:哎你那个叫应应用语言学是吗
Others: Hey, is your major Applied Linguistics?
Alice:嗯是
Alice: Yeah, it is.
其他人:就是中文的应用语言学对
Others: Applied Linguistics in Chinese, right?
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
其他人:可以
Others: Okay.
Alice:我已经换了好几个
Alice: I've already changed several...
Alice:也不是换了好几个专业就
Alice: Well, not exactly changed several majors, but...
Alice:东一榔头西一棒槌
Alice: Jumping from one thing to another.
其他人:但他是英语
Others: But his is in English.
其他人:你当时本科学的是物联网啊
Others: You studied the Internet of Things for your undergrad, right?
Tasha: 物联网啊
Tasha: Internet of Things?
其他人:你本科学的物联网
Others: You studied the Internet of Things for your undergrad.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
其他人：然后转文科的
Others: Then switch to arts.
Alice:是的高中理科
Alice: Yep, science in high school.
Alice:大学工科
Alice: Engineering in college.
Alice:研究生文科
Alice: Arts in grad school.
其他人：这是为什么
Others: Why is that?
Alice:好玩
Alice: It's fun.
其他人：物联网图
Others: Internet of Things.
其他人：毕业以后很好赚钱
Others: It's good for making money after graduation.
Alice:怎么说呢
Alice: How should I put it...
Alice:我感觉我还不是很想工作
Alice: I feel like I don't really want to work yet.
其他人:那你要读博
Others: Then you should pursue a PhD.
Alice:不想读博
Alice: I don't want to do a PhD.
其他人:那你想干吗
Others: Then what do you want to do?
Alice:我啊
Alice: Me?
其他人:家里蹲
Others: Stay at home.
Alice:倒也不用家里蹲吧
Alice: Not necessarily stay at home.
其他人:就是没想好
Others: So you haven't figured it out.
Alice:也不是没想好
Alice: It's not that I haven't figured it out.
Alice:我的想法就是我就想一直换工作
Alice: My idea is that I want to keep changing jobs.
Alice:你懂
Alice: You know?
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Alice:怎么说呢
Alice: How should I put it...
其他人:那你去实习吗
Others: Then are you going for an internship?
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
其他人：那不稳定吧
Others: That's not stable.
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
其他人:那不稳定
Others: That's unstable.
Alice:我要稳定干嘛呀
Alice: Why do I need stability?
Alice:那稳定那不直接考公务员了吗
Alice: If I wanted stability, I'd just take the civil service exam.
其他人:人家比较喜欢招稳定的
Others: People prefer to hire stable employees.
其他人:这是啥呀雪糯米这是你们买的
Others: What is this, snow glutinous rice? Did you guys buy this?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
其他人:这要做啥
Others: What's it for?
Alice:小料
Alice: A small dish.
Tasha: 用不上
Tasha: It's not needed.
其他人:然后发现没用
Others: And then found it's useless.
Tasha: 因为有一个材料没到
Tasha: Because one of the ingredients hasn't arrived.
其他人：这其实有剪刀
Others: Actually, there are scissors.
Alice:这个没用过
Alice: I've never used this before.
Tasha: 这个剪刀是剪肉的
Tasha: These scissors are for cutting meat.
其他人:这盖太大了
Others: This lid is too big.
其他人:这个轮胎不好熟感觉
Others: This tire doesn't seem to cook well.
Alice:弄开呗
Alice: Open it up then.
其他人:切开太薄了
Others: It's cut too thin.
Alice:太薄
Alice: Too thin.
其他人:切开太薄
Others: It's cut too thin.
Alice:切开怎么会薄呢
Alice: How can it be thin when cut?
Alice:你不这样分也不也行吗
Alice: Can't you divide it like this?
Alice:这不好切
Alice: This is hard to cut.